in the 1960s in the united states with
the passing of the civil rights act we
saw what many consider
to be sort of the official end of the
absolute
most explicit and formal types of
government
racism when we ended mandated
segregation we
outlawed many other types of racial
discrimination
but since then and really to this day
black and hispanic americans continue to
suffer from a variety
of social and economic inequities with
regard to wealth
education health outcomes cycles of
crime and incarceration
the list is a mile long when we're
talking about
socioeconomic adversities that
disproportionately impact
populations of color over the past 50 or
60 years
in the time since the civil rights
movement we've seen many racial equality
movements
try to illuminate and put a spotlight on
and address these problems
and these movements tend to acknowledge
that these problems
are the ripple effects of historical
institutional racism like slavery and
jim crow
and these movements have pushed for
solutions that are designed to help
these groups in particular
as remedies for problems that impact
them
disproportionately this has taken the
form
of affirmative action scholarships for
minority students
bussing to integrate schools federal
financial support for historically black
colleges government
programs that help minority businesses
these are all
forms of action that solve or try
to solve race-based problems in the
united states
over the past half century what we've
also seen consistently in parallel
is pushback against these racial
equality initiatives here are a few
clips
of some popular conservatives making
comments
which i believe accurately sum up sum up
the prevailing right-wing narrative on
systemic racism with regard to
socioeconomics
one could certainly say during the jim
crow era when when
you know african americans couldn't vote
that's systemic racism you have you have
things
in the system that are contributing to
racism
is systemic racism still a reality today
it is not a reality it is the opposite
of a reality it's
an illusion if you can point to me to
the law or the practice that's in place
that makes that
somehow keeps me out if there's two
people that that are working the exact
same and putting out the same exerting
the same amount of effort and you're
going to tell me that as a black person
i can't get ahead
it doesn't exist there are lots of rich
black people in america
and there are lots of poor white people
in america yeah so what so
because black people in the united
states are disproportionately poorer
than
white people in the united states it's
actually yeah it's ignoring the real
problem which is how do we get poor
people to be richer
systemic racism does not exist there are
no laws in america meaning the system
doesn't mean racism doesn't exist racism
exists there are people who are racist
and you should do everything you can to
show them that their ideas are wrong
and that you should not be judging
someone based on their race of course
but the idea that there is systemic
racism meaning that there are
laws in place that treat black people
differently or asian people differently
or white people differently
simply doesn't exist if you can get an
economy that's as free as possible you
will have more and more people
regardless
of the color of their skin being able to
partake in an economy
so those comments uh cover a bunch of
the predominant views
from the right on systemic racism those
were clips of
three of the most popular right-wing
online broadcasters so the first thing i
want to point out is
they are defining systemic racism so
narrowly
that it would only refer to racism by
the government
and only the most explicit and official
forms of government racism like
jim crow for example and that's how
they're able to say
that systemic racism doesn't exist if
someone's constantly asserting something
that everyone already accepts is true
such as slavery and jim crow no longer
exists
it's likely that they're either
accidentally or purposefully
misunderstanding what they are trying to
argue against
that's what's happening here i've never
encountered someone who asserts that
systemic racism is a problem today
while defining racism in such a narrow
way people usually use the term
systemic racism to denote any type of
racial biases formal
or informal by a system or someone
acting on behalf of a system
which could take the form of racial bias
by police officers
or by a law enforcement system racial
bias
by people hiring at a company racial
bias in education
like a standardized test that puts
certain racial
groups at a disadvantage it doesn't even
necessarily have to be racism by an
individual
importantly it could just be a system
doing something that
in practice disadvantages members of a
certain group
on the basis of their race and i think
that the concept
requiring a little bit of nuance is
exactly why
some people get confused some people get
defensive about the word racism being
involved
so maybe we can have a separate
conversation about finding a better term
which is fine
but that's what people mean when they
say there is active systemic racism
present in the year 2020. so i think a
lot of conservatives are confused about
the definition
if they act as though it's synonymous
only with slavery and jim crow
or some of them are straw manning in bad
faith
to avoid actually engaging with the
reality on the ground
but the conservatives i played in the
clips what they also
seem to be saying is that systemic
racism as someone like
me would define it doesn't exist their
sentiment is
slavery and jim crow are over black
people
no longer face any types of
disadvantages there are no systemic
biases against black people there are no
lingering effects from historical
institutional
uh inequality unfairness that still
leave
the deck stacked against minority
individuals black and white people on
average have identical opportunity to
succeed
they would assert the other thing they
seem to be saying
is that because they don't believe those
racial biases exist
we shouldn't be looking at minority
poverty
through the lens of race in order to
solve it
with racial social justice action
they say we should instead look at black
poverty for example
as an arbitrary piece of poverty as a
whole
and we should try to solve black poverty
merely by fixing poverty as a whole
and in addition to saying that racial
solutions to
for example black or hispanic poverty
are unnecessary often they will add
that those racial solutions dismiss
ignore or belittle white poverty
and they discount the personal
responsibility
of non-white individuals to improve
their own lives but it's not surprising
that that's the direction conservatives
would go
because each of those pieces fits
beautifully into
the conservative meta-narratives that
we've been following for example
racial inequality is generally overblown
identity politics is bad
government intervention is the wrong way
to fix anything capitalism and
meritocracy
ultimately are the answers to everything
what conservatives
like these are not realizing is that
there are social and economic problems
today in the united states that affect
minorities in specific ways black folks
as a group
do have certain types of particular
disadvantages and to admit that
is a reality doesn't mean that you're
deriding
the poverty of other races or in general
and it doesn't mean you're devaluing
anybody's individual responsibility
it doesn't mean that there aren't things
we can also be doing generally
to help everybody in a situation of
hardship regardless of race
of course we want to be thinking about
those solutions too and i talk about
those solutions every day
i might even agree with somebody like
ben shapiro when he says
that the mere existence of a black white
poverty gap
alone is not necessarily a justification
for using race
as the context to fix black poverty
the fact that black folks are
impoverished at a higher rate than white
people
by itself might not justify racial
solutions
as opposed to solutions that improve the
lives of all groups
but what these people on the right seem
never to recognize
is that certain opportunity gaps also
still exist
not only do black folks in many respects
have worse outcomes on average
black folks also have diminished
opportunity to improve those outcomes
compared to
white people on average on average
that's what these conservatives are
missing and it's the reason why it is
actually useful to explore
certain solutions that are tailored
towards certain particular racial
inequalities
in some ways black and white poverty can
be different there are many metrics
that illustrate gaps between a black
person and a white person of the same
income there was a groundbreaking study
by stanford and harvard researchers from
2018
which combined census data on race with
irs tax returns
allowing them to compare the income of
parents with the income of their grown
children
over the span of 1989 to 2015
for the purpose of tracking
intergenerational mobility which is the
degree to which children
economically surpass their parents or
fall behind and what they found
is that downward mobility occurs at a
much higher rate among black americans
than among white americans
when you compare black and white people
with similar incomes this was true even
among the children of higher income
parents of both races
children of white parents in the top
fifth of the income distribution
have a 41 percent chance of staying at
that income level
children of black parents in that
highest income level
only have an 18 chance of staying at
that income level so regardless of how
much money your parents make
if you are black you are less likely to
achieve the economic status
of your parents or higher sadly i can
already imagine some people
are going to butt in with oh well maybe
it has something to do with intelligence
or single parenthood or something like
that
the study found that the black white
mobility gap
is entirely driven by black and white
males there was very little gap between
black and white
females which would rule out genetic
factors between races as an explanation
if that's your sort of thing to look at
the study also looked at family
structure and
it found that the huge gap is there
regardless of whether children came from
one or two parent
homes which debunks the conservative
idea
that lower marriage rates are
responsible
but a factor that does tend to
powerfully predict economic mobility
is the average income of the
neighborhood in which a child was raised
a study by harvard economists published
in 2015
showed overwhelming evidence for this
the researchers looked at 16 years of
tax records
to track pairs of children and parents
and they found that the affluence of a
child's neighborhood
is the single best predictor of their
long-term upward mobility
the amount of money in an area where a
child grows up
is strongly correlated with that child's
ability to achieve
more socioeconomic success than their
parents
a study was published in 2015 by the
american academy of political and social
science conducted by researchers
at stanford by looking at census data
which found that
among black and white families with
similar incomes
white families are much more likely to
live in neighborhoods
with higher average incomes and of
course this means
that the white family is more likely to
have access to better schools
better child care better parks better
transportation
options the list of advantages in a high
income neighborhood
relative to a low income neighborhood is
a very very long list
and between a black and white family of
similar income
the difference between the average
incomes of their neighborhoods is not
small
it's huge so to put all of this together
we have
the mobility gap between black and white
people of similar incomes
the mobility of anyone regardless of
race
tends to be predicted by the average
income of the neighborhood where they
grew up
and we see that a black family with the
same income as a white family
is more likely to live in a poorer
neighborhood
and that's because black people tend to
live near other black people
and black people have lower incomes than
white people
on average and of course that is what we
call racial housing segregation the
geographic
separation of races and it is a racial
issue so
we've demonstrated one of many examples
of a social problem in 2020
which can be usefully analyzed in terms
of race and it warrants
racial justice action the problem is
that black folks have
less upward mobility than white folks
the cause of the problem
is racial housing segregation and the
solution
would be integrating housing to a
greater degree
there are so many other examples of
social problems today
that demand racial justice solutions in
education healthcare the justice system
i'd have nowhere near enough time in
this video to go
into each and every one of them so let's
flesh out
this example we're dealing with housing
segregation before we start talking
about solutions to segregation we should
contemplate
how the housing segregation that exists
today came to be
a lot of people think that people of the
same races
ended up living in the same areas
accidentally or as a result of personal
choice
but actually most of today's racial
segregation in every city across america
results from explicitly racist
government policies
throughout the late 19th and early 20th
century many american cities passed
zoning ordinances prohibiting black
people from moving on to
a block that was majority white starting
in 1934 the federal government
gave white people better access to
affordable mortgages
while designating black neighborhoods in
cities across america
as zones where banks should not offer
mortgages this was known as redlining
which encouraged white people
to move to homogenously white suburbs
and it trapped black people in decaying
neighborhoods
also in the 1930s the public works
administration
built tens of thousands of public
housing complexes all over the country
all of which had a designation for which
racial group was allowed to live there
and almost all of them were either all
white or all black and much of the
racial segregation
that it caused is still present today
there are plenty of other instances of
government mandating
racial housing segregation deliberate
codified
government racism is what gave us almost
all of the housing segregation we see
today and now
white people and black people are more
segregated from one another
then white people are segregated from
asian or hispanic people as
examples and more so than poor and
non-poor people
are segregated from one another and
black white
segregation puts a hugely unfair burden
on black people it has much worse
effects for a black family living in a
black neighborhood
who have the same income and education
as a white family living in a white
neighborhood
the average middle-class black family
lives in a neighborhood with a higher
poverty rate
than the average low-income white person
segregation also prevents home values
from appreciating
in black neighborhoods because of white
folks reluctance to buy a home in a
black neighborhood
even when all other attributes of homes
and neighborhoods are equal
which by the way is an example of
systemic racism happening
actively in the year 2020 and it's a
type of systemic racism with a huge
impact on black wealth
since someone's home is often their
largest financial asset
so the crucial thing here is that higher
poverty rates in the neighborhood
means lower quality resources for
everyone who lives there
segregation is the biggest barrier
between
black people and higher income wealth
better education health care employment
opportunities and so on
one might even be able to say that today
the government's refusal to integrate
housing more effectively
to fix the problems that government
created originally
could itself be another example of
ongoing systemic racism in 2020
the government not doing something is
just as much a policy decision as the
government
doing something sure someone like ben
shapiro
can sit back and say yeah okay whatever
happened in the past with racism and
segregation was bad but
now that the government has stopped
actively mandating segregation we can
just wipe the slate clean we can just
blame
individual black people for being poor
but that would be a complete
misunderstanding of the forces that
created these problems and the forces
that would be necessary to fix them
government has a ton of power obviously
and it used this power to segregate for
a long time
that same amount of power would be
required to undo it
this is where we get to the distinction
between desegregation
and integration desegregation is when a
government stops
separating people integration is the
process of unseparating those same
people which has not happened
so we're currently stuck in a state of
segregation essentially in a way the
civil rights act did not accomplish as
much as conservatives seem to think it
did
it didn't hit the reset button on racial
inequality racial groups in the united
states are not
on a level playing field so what can
government do to counteract segregation
as a way to give black people more
economic opportunity well
to start with we could reinstitute the
obama-era policy
of requiring localities that receive
federal money for housing
to identify and try to remedy housing
practices that promote racial bias
the policy that was suspended by the
trump administration which donald trump
completely blew out of proportion in
terms of what it did and
uh donald trump has made clear that he
has no interest in dealing with that
issue and in fact
in his personal past has a history of
racial housing discrimination
commenting on his elimination of this
anti-racist policy trump actually
tweeted
i am happy to inform all of the people
living in their suburban lifestyle dream
that you will no longer be bothered or
financially hurt
by having low income housing built in
your neighborhood enjoy
that's another example of institutional
racism in 2020 if i've ever seen one
another step we could take to counter
segregation
by reducing housing discrimination is to
increase
the use of fair housing testers who are
individuals who
pose as potential buyers and renters to
gather information
on possible instances of illegal
racial housing discrimination because
this discrimination tends to push black
people
out of white areas tests like these have
been funded by the department of housing
and urban development
and they've uncovered a staggering
amount of racial discrimination for
example they did a test in chicago
in 2018 and identified racial
discrimination
27 of the time there's
some more current systemic racism as an
example for you nevertheless
hud does not fund these tests anywhere
near the level
that matches how pervasive and
destructive we've observed this problem
to be
we have to be better about enforcing
anti-housing discrimination laws
that are already on the books government
could also be bolstering
inclusionary zoning policies which
require home builders to make sure that
portions of new housing units are
affordable to low and moderate income
people
to eliminate the financial barriers that
often end up keeping poor black families
from finding an affordable home in a
good neighborhood
we could also be using more federal
housing subsidies to
help lower-income black families move
into better neighborhoods the low-income
housing
tax credit could be used to develop
subsidized rental housing
in non-poor neighborhoods there is great
new research that it
illustrates that what we have been doing
with this
has had huge payoffs especially for the
kids
of low-income families there are many
other strategies
we could be using to um
disperse black families so that lower
income households
aren't so concentrated new policies that
can be implemented and
through better funding and enforcement
of initiatives that already exist
could be significantly beneficial but i
wanted to
explore just racial housing segregation
as an example
to illustrate some points about systemic
racism and how much can be done about it
it's a topic that is always relevant and
worthy of a deep dive
but especially right now with everything
going on with black lives matter the
discussions around race that are
happening
over the past few months while they've
had the country's attention
black folks in the u.s and allies
of all kinds have been trying to shed
light on a number of
really important problems in the country
things that this country has to start
dealing with it's way overdue
but i'm seeing some people actually
confused about what are even the
starting points for these conversations
the reality is racism can take many
different forms some people just have an
overly simplistic
conception of what racism is people
start talking about systemic racism
conservatives respond with
i have no idea what you're talking about
we have no more slavery jim crow is over
we ended that a long time ago so racial
injustice no longer exists
that perspective misunderstands
deliberately
or accidentally what systemic racism is
and it ignores
the fact that systemic racism exists and
is just another form of racism we also
have to refute
the common conservative notion that
black
hardships can only be productively
discussed
in the context of hardship or poverty in
general
instead of acknowledging additional
racial components that are often
involved
there are some issues that are more
accurately understood
when you take into account racial
injustices that may be at play
so that you can solve them with
specially catered solutions